اذا الفن ورمزيات حراك يصعب وقفه في ايران
لكن ان كانت الانتفاضه ان تحملوا شعارا
يمثلها فحتما مشاهدينا سيكون هذا هو
الشعار مؤشر نبض الاحتجاجات ومصدر خوف حكم
الملالي جامعه الشريف للتكنولوجيا ومدرسه
النخبه التقنيه في ايران حين تتعالى من
هذا الحرم العريق تتعاظم الصعوبات امام
السلطات والامن للسيطره على مستقبل البلاد
مركز احتجاجات الثوره
الرئيسيه الحاليه ومصدر الهام 130 جامعه
ينتفض طلابها بوجه البسيج لكن لماذا جامعه
الشريف هذه نقطه جذب المع العقول
الايرانيه الطلاب التقنيين طلاب الصناعات
وطلاب العلوم النوويه والفضاء بشكل خاص
لطالما كانت هذه التخصصات في عهد الخميني
وخامنه من بعده تمنح الطلاب مرتبه
اجتماعيه مختلفه وفرصا مؤكده في المراكز
الحساسه وهنا يظهر وجه الاحتجاج الحقيقي
اجابه احد اعضاء اتحاد طلاب جامعه شريف
الوكاله الفرنسيه
حمام عزيز باشا